dashing out C plus plus software episode
two let's talk a little bit about
logging and I guess we'll say decoupling
because that's kind of what I'm working
with today here on this uh little piece
of software I'm working on now I want to
make it clear that this series isn't
about this program it's just about uh
decisions made while programming and
putting things together so in the future
you know we could do episodes on
anything any piece of software but for
now you know this is what I'm working on
this is where I thought of the example
so just want to make that somewhat clear
all right so I have a window system you
know just pops up a window so we can
draw stuff to it um
and it's got a link to the graphics so
at some point you got to do this whole
proc thing
and the problem with this is now if you
call this within your window class that
means you've now you don't have it
directly coupled to well I don't know
whatever you're calling here like this
would be open jail for example I have it
directly coupled to opengl so it makes
it less modular it makes it kind of hard
to adapt to a new render for example
you'd have to like hard code in the new
renderer stuff and we don't really want
to do that you know we want to avoid
having to repeat ourselves and hard code
and hard couple I mean sometimes it's
okay but at some point you got to change
it up and also with logging you know
there's a lot of different ways to do
logging you can just use standard C outs
if you want but at some point you're
going to want at least a basic logging
implementation for what you're doing so
I want to start with that I'll start
with showing the logging thing and then
a little later I'll talk more about
decoupling this uh this Graphics from
the window essentially we want the
window to have no knowledge of anything
opengl like this glue should be gone
screws a open gel thing
so that'll be our goal with that all
right so let's make the login thing
first so to make a log you know you got
to think about how do you want to
present your log you can save it to a
file you can put it to console you could
just not do it at all so those are the
basic options and I'm just going to put
something in here I'm just going to make
a new file you can see it over on the
right probably very small for you and
I'm going to call it uh I suppose
logging is a fine title logging.h we're
going to make an Associated C plus plus
file because that's how I'm doing it in
this project I also want to make a video
I was thinking about this I'm just going
to say it out loud so I'd be sure to
remember to do it I want to make a video
about the different ways of doing your
header and CPP files I know it sounds
very corny but there's like two main
ways of doing it and uh yeah but I don't
want to get too off topic this one Let's
uh make this logging class I think I'm
gonna call it logger instead of logging
so just rename this now this is going to
be a Singleton I think because uh
I don't want to make a bunch of these we
just want there to be one so if it's a
Singleton we're gonna put a main
Constructor
private and we're gonna make an accessor
slash Creator function and we're also
going to make the Blogger internally
hold itself so to hold itself we need to
make this static to make this static we
need to initialize it in a C plus plus
file we're going to do that in a log
dot CVP
all right so we include this we make
sure we scope this into logger
and we'll just essentially have most of
a Singleton and get rid of this static
over on this side and we can initialize
it to null pointer and there we go now
we just need to wait to set that up so
we'll make a function that does it and
we can take this a step further and
make this a unique pointer we do need to
include memory for this this will just
make it a little bit easier to manage
the memory we can still return just the
pointer like that but this now needs to
have a correct type over here
so we want an initializer function and
that's what this is going to be actually
right it's going to be some function
that returns a pointer we could just
make it a knit now if this is going to
off to that static member you'll see
watch what happens when we try to just
instantiate this watch let's Go
Singleton logger equals standard make
unique one unique logger now we want to
make sure we don't do this every time
they call a knit but just a single time
rather in this Singleton logger since
it's a unique pointer we gotta use the
dot get method to get the raw pointer
out of it to return there
and since we don't want to initialize
this every single time we call a knit
just a single time we need to put a
clause here
just a little if statement says if it's
not loaded or not
something
if it's currently null rather you
initialize it and then you just return
that pointer so that should work from a
knit function but I don't think it's
going to actually compile actually
should yeah this is fine
now the interesting thing is that it
returns this function or it Returns the
Singleton we probably want some sort of
macro that basically handles all this
for us
so let's just like include i o stream
here
and let's make a log function and again
it's fine here I don't know I kind of
like this being get it's just that a
knit implies we're not really returning
anything
so maybe that'll be a little better
let's not return anything on this one
and we will have a get method or a log
method or we could just have an operator
overload here
and I need to look this up because I
forget how to do this particular one and
it looks like for this one you need to
do it as a friend
that returns an O stream because that's
what's taken in that we can chain them
and it takes okay so oh stream we're
gonna need to work with those stream a
little bit that's in standard standard
and this is just how we're going to set
it to default you know if we want to do
file outputs those can fit into ostream
which is nice and they have a oh that's
just the example I'm looking at has a
date for us here we're going to be
passing in probably strings
but really we want to be able to pass in
kind of any I guess any sort of data in
Dairy but uh I guess that gets
complicated pretty fast
so yeah this will just be the log or the
message and we need to create this
function here and at the end we
definitely need to return the O string
same one that was passed in because
basically we're going to stream whatever
this message is and that's all this is
going to do now what this allows us to
do is just call the loggers uh operator
so if we use logger
we can essentially use this for anywhere
where we might be doing some C outs or
anything along those lines or even maybe
throw cases we could we could log there
too but we can uh
kind of make some decisions around this
and if we want to change it we don't got
to go to Every file where we have a
throw or a c out or an error or anything
we only have to change it in one file so
that's that's the big Advantage here it
makes a lot more maintainable to say hey
uh you know we used to do it the hard
way but now all the logs are in one
place so you can just call this thing
anytime you want we could you know there
are other ways we could design this we
could essentially make this some sort of
Observer and attached a bunch of things
and allow it to observe events and log
them
so we could do something like that or we
could also have it take commands about
how to log it but for now I think we're
just going to keep it a Singleton and
let people call it directly now this
makes it pretty pretty Global and
potentially a little cash unfriendly so
what we're basically going to end up
doing is we're going to have some if
diffs around it and we're only going to
log and debug mode so when we build our
release it won't even have any of this
logger code so that will be kind of the
main point of this logger and uh see I
got a lot more to do but we're out of
time for this episode I'll post an
extended version up on the patreon if
you want to see a nice chunk of where
this goes next and uh hear me talking
more basically all right appreciate you
guys and the sport happy coding peace